[Music]
we start this NewsHour in Pakistan where
the election commission has disqualified
former prime minister Imran Khan from
running for office the commission says
Khan is guilty of unlawfully selling
State gifts received from heads of state
and foreign dignitaries Khan's Aid says
they will challenge the ruling or the
case against the former leader was filed
in August
let's speak now to Kamal Haider who's in
majan in swat Valley and obviously this
is a hugely significant development
Kamal
usually significant given the fact that
Imran Khan the former prime minister of
Pakistan won a landslide victory in the
by-elections just recently he is still
commands a tremendous support across the
country this particular case of course
is seen as controversial given the fact
that the legal fraternity particularly
the legal team for the former prime
minister has said that the charges are
politically motivated there is of course
a caveat within the Pakistani rules
because all the gifts received by the
head of state or senior ministers in
Pakistan can be brought back initially
it was a rule that you had to pay 25
percent of the price Imran had raised
that to 50 percent and of course the
opposition saying that they were
irregularities as the legal team also
saying that D cannot be disqualified by
the election commission of Pakistan
which does not have the jurisdiction of
a court and therefore his legal team of
course is immediately are going to go to
the upper Court the Supreme Court or the
Islamabad High Court where they will
challenge it saying that the election
commission does not have the mandate to
disqualify anyone that is the
jurisdiction of the courts and this of
course is coming at the time of great
political instability within Pakistan
because Imran Khan had threatened that
his supporters will march on Islamabad
lay Siege to the capital in order for
his demands to be accepted so a dramatic
development indeed and there is going to
be a reaction the reaction of course the
weighted the party leaders of course
will announce possibly protests across
the country and is supporters are also
going to come out in large numbers to
win their anger so indeed The crucial
developments but that also coming from
the election commission and the argument
being that this is a political Vendetta
the ruling opposition Alliance has been
trying to implicate him in one case or
another there is of course the contempt
of court case in which he was cleared
and also slapped terrorism charges
against him he was cleared of that also
but there was an expectation that the
election commissioner who Imran Khan's
party and Imran Khan the former prime
minister says is playing uh along uh to
the gallery of the opposition that is in
cahoots with them so indeed huge
developments as far as Pakistan is
concerned and this of course will have
grave implications for Pakistan's
political instability as well thank you
very much that's Kamal harder for us in
smart Valley